so here we go oh look at rich rich
Corinthian leather here this is awesome
um so here's what we're going to
do we I used to do all these all by
myself but I think it's a lot of fun no
no I think it's a lot of fun here when
we let you
guys to do it by yourself okay sorry um
the East Front Court you pass pass that
to the chuckster if you would please ER
don't let them do it I don't have to be
able to read Jack uh it it would be
helpful here you just had
go ahead Chuck finish the joke okay
ladies and gentlemen the East Front
Court led by the
captain
jannis
antio here we Goose it's not yes it is
in too many years you can't eight
straight Allstar appearances for The
Greek Freak in his 11th season averaging
and six he's third in scoring fifth in
rebounding top 20 in assists uh 25 games
of 30 plus six of 40 plus and had 64
against Indiana earlier this season what
would be the next card you have
truckster he only had six to four
somebody else had more the next is from
my Philadelphia 7 Sixers Mr Joel mbid
yes the uh the reigning
MVP seven straight Allstar
selections leads the league in scoring
with 36 a night averaging 12 rebounds
which is number six averaging a
career-high six assists as well while
shooting
54% and um of course he had that
70-point game against the San Antonio
Spurs who would be the who would be the
final front last and definitely not
least from the Boston Celtics Mr Jason t
tatm there you go 25-year-old Jason
Tatum his fifth Allstar selection fifth
straight 27 points a night that's ninth
in the league eight rebounds four
assists playing in 41 of their 44 games
17 games of at least 30 points so what
do you think of your Eastern Conference
front Court there chuckster I uh they
got the right three uh you know jel and
be got one MVP last year here and is
playing be this year uh and obviously
the other two guys are fantastic so I
got no problem with those three guys I'm
looking at the breakdown here that they
have of fans players and media so the
player rank for Giannis was number one
embiid was two Tatum was three fans had
it one two three with the uh Giannis
Tatum and embiid third the media had
Giannis Joel
and Tatum 123 the fourth place finisher
by the way was Jaylen Brown of the
Boston Celtics shall we move on to the
east guards Kenny would you uh would do
the
honors going to be reading two names one
at a time here found it out sound it out
Kenny a
Tumo how about that I did I I gave the
wrong envelope guy said sound it out
just told that man can't
read oh this is great
from the Indiana Paces Tyrese halberton
yes the uh League leader and assist she
had a tremendous year wait when is the
allstar game oh my gosh middle of
February man he's out he's out cuz he's
out three weeks that was my that's the
point I was trying to make I hope he's
able to play Man especially at home the
crib he going to play Oh D he got a bad
hamstring 24 points a game uh 13 assists
the best Mark in the NBA uh seven games
of 30 plus and he makes it for the
second straight time in his Tyrese
halberton uh Eastern Conference starting
guard there's a there's a spot for
another guard here there's another
spot and he's a good one from the
Milwaukee Bucks Damen Lillard Damen
Lillard the starting
alongside Tyrese halberton daman's 32
years old now it's eighth Allstar
appearance in his 12th season he's given
the Bucks 25 points a game that's 16th
in the
league uh number 12 and assist with
seven a game and uh Dame time in
Indianapolis as he joins Tyrese
halberton Kenny as starting guards for
the East what do you think uh no
complaints I mean these two guys
are difficult to guard difficult to
leave off any list that says a star
behind behind
it yeah the breakdown on this now uh in
the player vote halberton first Damian
Lillard was
fourth who was second on the player rank
Tyrese
Maxi fan vote halberton
first Trey young second Lillard third
media vote halberton first Jaylen
Brunson second Damen Lillard was fifth
but of course these are all all weighted
in the 50 2525 it comes out Tyrese
halberton over Damen Lillard and um it's
man it was just so tight between Brunson
and Lillard for that starting spot but
it goes to uh wow Damen Lillard um okay
West Front Court Dr O'Neal you know I
know how to read yes I
do hamburger french fries french
toast
toast all right the captain from the Los
Angeles Lakers the King LeBron James
this makes 20 straight
appearances most All-Star appearances
ever ever belongs to LeBron James at 39
wow 25 points a game seven rebounds
seven assists three-time allstar game
MVP
and uh the quote Captain the captain
thing is more of a like a ceremonial
yeah because you we're not having the
draft anymore but uh oh no draft anymore
no no draft anymore so nobody gets left
last no so so le Lebron James uh is
there two more two more there two more
the next name he plays for the Phoenix
Suns and he goes by the name of Kevin
Durant yes indeed uh sons have been on a
roll 26 and 18 14 times Allstar now uhow
scoring 29 six rebounds six assists and
uh shooting 45% from Deep which is
number four in the league so Kevin
Durant once again an All-Star four time
scoring champion and of course Kenny
two-time horse Champion yes Kevin Durant
who's your who's your final front Court
starter in the final front Court starter
is the vice president of the big man
Alliance goes by the name of Nicola
yic I say that right yic yes you did the
Joker you read six straight appearances
fourth straight start ninth season for
the Joker 26 points a game 12 rebounds
nine assists tied for the league lead in
double doubles with damus sabonis leads
the league in triple doubles wow that's
impressive with 13 and so those are your
three in the Western Conference in the
front Court uh Lebron
jic Durant LeBron was number two in the
player voting uh Joker was one Durant
was three fans had it LeBron Joker
Durant and uh in the media it was Joker
LeBron and Durant Anthony Davis was
fourth and kawhai Leonard fifth in the
voting uh which brings us to the last
envelope and that would be the West
guards
leading it off from the Dallas Mavericks
Luca
donic so
Luca no surprise no surprise fifth great
All-Star selection sixth season um
here's a guy giving you 34 which is
second in the league also a career high
eight rebounds nine assists he's number
three in the league and assists 48%
shooter 37% from Deep which is a career
high in 29 games of at least 30 points
and so that leaves us one more one spot
Allstar
starter in the back court starting guard
joining Luca Donis Shay gilgas Alexander
well deserved of the Oklahoma City
Thunder nobody's got more 30-point games
in the League this year than SGA 32 of
those five games of at least 40 points
and he makes the all stars for the
second time in his sixth season 31
points a night six rebounds and six
assists shooting a career high
55% sh wow B well deserved I'm happy for
him uh you know true definition of hard
work pays off very very hky jerky type
player very hard to guard but I'm happy
for him both East and the West election
can be mad about you know of course
every year you know you they're very
subjective of he should have been he
should have been there but I'm not mad
at the East or the West starting five
Luca and Shay gilgas Alexander um SGA
was number one in the player vote uh
Luca was number two Steph was number
three fans had Luca Steph and SGA and
the media had sgaa Luca and Anthony
Edwards third followed by Stephen Curry
but overall all Curry finishes third
Edwards fourth in that balloting so big
picture you know we look at what we've
what we've just witnessed here Chuck and
what's your
takeaway well I I actually like when you
were going over I like what the player
said I got none I'm never gonna show
throw shade at Dame Lillard I love him
as a person and as a player but I would
have loved to see Jaylen Bronson be a
starter I said this last year I I can't
believe what a great player he's turned
into when he went to the Knicks last
year I was like that's a good signing
it's one of the best signings I've ever
seen for a free agent nobody knew he was
going to be that good you know uh he has
been fantastic he's made the Knicks
relevant and uh I would love you don't
think the Lakers signing Shaq was no
Shaq was all Hall of Famer you said one
of the greatest signings free AG it is
one of the greatest did he say that fact
did he not say that stick by that but it
is a great free it's not it's not
bringing Shaq to Los Angeles no but sh
but listen Shaq was already one of the
best players in the world ever nobody
thought no no nobody thought Jaylen
Bronson was going to be as good as he is
you don't think bringing Kevin Durant to
Golden State was a great those guys were
already made men okay nobody thought
Jaylen Bron was GNA be no he's great I
mean I'm happy for him he's going to be
an Allstar but he's going to be an allar
but but I'm saying I'm saying that's one
of the greatest free agent in
it's my opinion like Shaq and Kevin
Durant those guys Hall of famous they
were already great players when they got
traded nobody and I guarantee you if the
Knicks be honest with you they didn't
think he was G to be this good they
thought he would be an upgrade but what
Jaylen Bronson has did for the Knicks he
made the New York Knicks relevant for
the first time since Patrick y plain and
simple 27 points a game for Jaylen
Brunson four rebounds and six assists
playing in 42 of their 44 games and I
should point out I talked about how
close that race was between Damen
Lillard and Jaylen Brunson actually
identical finishing scores of
3.75 but because Lillard had more fan
votes that is the tiebreaker so Damen
Lillard becomes the starter for the
Eastern Conference in the back
court